eigentlich wollte ich erklären wie
fliegen funktioniert aber das scheint
ein ungeklärter fall der wissenschaft zu
sein
die experten sind sich nämlich nicht
einig was da eigentlich genau passiert
es ist wirklich zu mäuse melken
eigentlich ist fliegen ja nicht tierisch
kompliziertes habe ich zumindest gedacht
aber da sei schwer auf dem holzweg bei
der recherche bin ich auf eine seite der
nasa gestoßen
und da steht klipp und klar ich lese es
direkt mal in deutsch vor
es gibt viele erklärungen für die
entstehung von auftrieb in lexika liegt
büchern und im internet
unglücklicherweise hören viele dieser
erklärungen in die irre oder sind falsch
wie bitte lexika und sogar fachbücher
sollen falsch sein
also ich kann es nicht glauben und ich
bin ansonsten auch kein anhänger von
verschwörungstheorien
aber mir drängt sich hier schon ein
bisschen der verdacht auf dass durch die
gebetsmühlenartige wiederholung einer
falsche oder zumindest lückenhaften
theorie die leute beruhigt werden damit
sie ohne jeglichen zweifel in ein
flugzeug steigen
doch zweifel sind hier mehr als
berechtigt fliegen wird meistens
folgendermaßen erklärt die oberseite
eines flügels hat eine größere
oberfläche und da die luftmoleküle am
ende wieder zusammentreffen würde auf
der oberen seite die luft einen längeren
weg zurücklegen also muss sie das
schneller tun und schnellere luft hat
einen geringeren druck es entsteht also
ein unterdruck an der oberseite des
flügels und das flugzeug wird nach oben
gezogen richtig ist schnellere luft
erzeugt unter druck ein schneller
luftstrom hat einen geringeren druck als
ein langsamerer kann man auch ganz
einfach ausprobieren übrigens an daniel
bernoulli anfang des achtzehnten
jahrhunderts herausgefunden und das
sieht dann etwa so aus
einfach drüber blasen und schon steht
das blatt papier waagerecht in der luft
durch unterdruck nach oben gezogen ja
dann wäre ja eigentlich alles ganz klar
so funktioniert fliegen
es gibt nur einen klitzekleinen haken
wenn ein flugzeug fliegt gibt es ja noch
den luftstrom unten drunter und warum
sich vorne am flügel luftmoleküle
verabreden sollten hinten wieder
zusammen zu treffen
das kann einem niemand erklären auch
flacher flügel profile wie zb
papierflieger könnten ja dann gar nicht
fliegen wenn das genauso funktionieren
würde kunstflieger würden bei
symmetrisches flügelprofil haben
abstürzen und ein dreieck also was unten
angeschrägt ist und oben schlacht ist
könnte auch keinen auftrieb erfahren
also fliegen würde zum teil nicht
funktionieren auch wenn man die
geschichte der fliegerei ansieht die
ersten flugzeuge hatten sehr sehr flache
flügelprofil werden also riesenprobleme
haben müssen in die luft zu kommen
hatten sie aber nicht sie flogen und
hoben ab probieren geht über studieren
ich habe mir also ein styropor blog
gekauft und ein paar flügel profile
herausgesägt um auszuprobieren was
fliegt denn eigentlich mit der
unterstützung von denen sind wir also
los gefahren und haben mal geguckt was
da so passiert ja und schon die hand im
fahrtwind lässt er an dass es auch ohne
bernie geht sie wird nach oben gedrückt
obwohl sie überhaupt kein flügelprofil
hat wirklich sie an möglich so wird man
schon sein oben weggedrückt und wenn wir
jetzt ein einfaches bett nehmen selbst
das wird je nachdem in welchem winkel
man es in die luft hält also welchen
anstellwinkel ist ab so nennt man das in
der luftfahrt wird auch ein flaches
brett nach oben gedrückt und wenn man
jetzt das flügelprofil nimmt es erfährt
tatsächlich schon eine gewisse kraft
nach oben auch wenn man es flach hält
aber richtig druck bekommt es wenn es
auch mit einem gewissen anstellwinkel in
die luft gehalten wird
da sollte es eigentlich weil nach oben
gehen aber nicht so halte so genau
gerade spüre ich eigentlich gar nicht so
vielleicht darf ich halte wenn ich so
halte ja dann spürt man schon noch dass
nach oben geht was dann wohl am unter
druck ihren ein bisschen so angesteckt
da geht's auf jeden fall deutlich mehr
nach oben und das dreieck das führt
jetzt bern uli absurdum obwohl es das
umgekehrte profil eines flügels hat also
unten ist die längere strecke trotzdem
wird das dreieck nach oben gedrückt so
dass mit so einem ganz normalen dreieck
mit der spitze nach vorne
so erhalten ist auf jeden fall ein druck
nach vorne
und je weiter man es anstellt ist
stärker nach oben genau nach oben auf
jeden fall kann ich nach unten da unten
gar nicht wenn man es jetzt nach unten
gar nicht also irgendwas stimmt nicht an
der herkömmlichen erklärung warum
flugzeuge fliegen ganz klar auch ohne
wenn oli funktioniert fliegen und beim
dreieck hat man es ganz deutlich gesehen
an der oberseite dieses tracks gibt es
keinen unter druck und trotzdem wird das
dreieck nach oben gedrückt und hier
kommt dann isaac newton ins spiel
er sagt ja aktie gleich reaktion das
heißt eine kraft wird zum beispiel an
dieser flügel unterseite je nach
anstellwinkel in zwei komponenten
zerlegt die eine drückt den flügel nach
hinten
dazu gibt es dann schob der dagegen
drückt in unserem experiment ist es den
us hand die das dreieck hält in realität
dann propeller oder nüsse und eine
weitere komponente drückt dann das
profil nach oben und erzeugt auftrieb
also auch ohne bailly und nur mit einer
minuten funktioniert fliegen ohne newton
und nur mit der herkömmlichen erklärung
könnte fliegen also gar nicht
funktionieren aber ohne ben ali geht es
auch nicht also beide theorien spielen
eine große rolle dabei zu erklären warum
ein flugzeug abhebt zwei amerikanische
aerodynamiker widersprechen dem aber
rigoros david anderson und scott sagen
wenn uli ist quatsch es ist der korando
effekt
und der diese theorie besagt dass
schnell strömende gase an oberflächen an
haften also die flügeloberfläche gar
nicht verlassen können und auf diese
weise der unterdruck erzeugt wird und es
gibt noch eine theorie besagt der neue
ja stimmt richtig aber das liegt daran
dass die luft vor dem flügel zusammen
gestaut wird also so richtig gespannt
wird wie bei einer schleuder und dann
zack über dem flügel flitsch und unter
dem flügel entlang fließt und da spielt
dann wieder die strecke eine rolle und
oben wird dann ein größerer unter druck
erzeugen also eins ist klar nichts ist
klar
laut dem deutschen journalisten dagobert
lindlau soll sogar bei lok ii einen
großen amerikanischen flugzeugbauer ein
plakat engen auf dem steht die flügel
fläche einer hummel ist im verhältnis zu
ihrem gewicht viel zu klein
sie kann daher nicht fliegen da sie das
aber nicht weiß fliegt sie doch und es
ist tatsächlich so niemand kann erklären
warum eine hummeln fliegen kann
aber es kommt noch besser der leiter des
instituts für flugzeugbau an der
stuttgarter universität rudolf voit
nitschmann der hat gegenüber der
wochenzeitschrift die zeit erklärt das
fliegen gehört wohl zu den phänomenen
die wir in der natur beobachten und
einfach hinnehmen müssen
also schluss aus ende vorbei
niemand kann also so richtig perfekt
erklären warum fliegen eigentlich
funktioniert wir können aber beruhigt
sein es ist millionenfach bewiesen dass
flugzeuge in der luft bleiben wir können
also ganz beruhigt in ein
passagierflugzeug einsteigen und was das
ganze mit einem der größten rätsel der
physik zu tun hat nämlich dem warum
teekannen tropfen
das erkläre ich demnächst mal hier geht
es direkt weiter mit dem letzten video
wird ein gamma blitz die erde zerstören
der hec den blitz aller zeiten und hier
oben gehts zum blog da gibt es alles
noch einmal zum nachlesen
mir bleibt jetzt nur noch das
traditionelle bis dann bleibt dran